你知道嗎？越南有一家公司TMT Motors，他們準備推出一款電動車，價格只要5,650美元。
5,650美元？這數字怎麼聽都覺得怪怪的。現在電動車普遍都還很貴吧？這會不會是那種連輪子都買不起的半成品？
其實我一開始也不太看好，不過原文有提到，這款車型號是Nano S05，是兩人座的電動微型車，主要瞄準的是越南擁擠的城市通勤市場。
兩人座… 嗯，這樣聽起來比較合理了。但就算只是微型車，這個價格也出乎意料了。他們怎麼做到的？總不可能隨便組裝一下就賣吧？
原文有說，TMT Motors原本是卡車製造商，也幫印度的Tata Motors和中國的Sinotruk組裝車輛。他們有技術和組裝經驗。
喔，所以是有底子的。這點我是信了。不過，就算是這樣，電動車的電池、馬達這些核心零件成本很高，怎麼可能壓到這個價位？這模式撐得久嗎？
他們的策略就是走極致成本領先，直接挑戰「電動車必昂貴」的傳統認知。他們很可能就是瞄準那些對價格敏感、追求基本代步需求的客群。
我猜啦，他們可能是學習了某些新興市場的打法，用非常簡約的設計和功能，加上大規模採購或在地化生產，才有機會壓低成本。但這樣會不會影響品質？
這點原文倒是沒詳細說明。但他們是想把價格壓到跟越南的「高級摩托車」差不多。這讓我覺得很有意思，他們不是要跟特斯拉競爭，而是要搶摩托車的市場。
這就說得通了。等於是把電動車下放到一個全新的消費層級。那對我們台灣的中小企業來說，能學到什麼？總不能叫我們也去賣電動車吧？
這點其實就是重點了。這個案例證明，就算是在高科技或新興產業，你可能沒想到，反其道而行透過成本控制或商業模式創新，還是能找到差異化定位。
怎麼說呢？就是不要盲目追求高科技、高大上，而是從最基本的痛點和需求切入，對嗎？
對，如果我是創業者，我會從這裡學到，當你資源有限時，不必非得追趕最頂尖的技術，而是可以思考市場上還沒有被滿足的「低價位」需求。
嗯，這確實是。就像很多新創公司，不一定要做最複雜的App，有時候一個簡單但實用的工具反而能打穿市場。那一般上班族呢？能從中得到什麼啟發？
像我們上班族，把這個概念帶入工作，就是當你接到一個專案或任務時，與其一開始就想著「要做到最完美、最高規格」，不如先問問自己：有沒有一種「夠用就好」但價格或成本最低的方案？
這讓我想到一件事，有時候老闆要求的，可能不是豪華大餐，而只是一個能止餓的便當。但我們自己卻常常想得太複雜。
對啊，或者在生活消費上，我們是不是也常常被「必昂貴」的刻板印象綁住？其實可能有很多「平價替代品」就能滿足大部分需求。
感覺這個越南TMT Motors的案例，好像也提醒了我們，在任何領域，多思考「如何用更少資源達成目標」這種出乎意料的思維，可能會找到新的出路。